hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
the standout title from e3 2017 was
anthem by always shared well shooter
coming in 2018 due to how this product
was placed many people don't know that
this will be available on the ps4 I've
gone through the footage many times and
I think it's time to outlines 10 reasons
why you should be excited about anthem
and a few reasons why you should be
worried too we hear it an awful lot
these days but anthem will be an
open-world adventure you are able to
explore and find new areas unlocking
them on your map what's really
impressive at this stage is the
aesthetic just look at the dense forest
and the high quality visuals not just
that but the verticality of the world in
breathtaking we're pretty much another
world to be found underneath the water
it definitely has an MMORPG feel and
when combined with other players this
will be a wonderful game to watch let
alone play something which may not be
important to everyone is the ability to
switch between first and third person
views I know many people who will not
try a game if they are faster play from
the character's point of view Anthon
will use a first-person view when in
safe areas like for Tarsus but when you
are out in the world the view will
change the third-person but the camera
will come closer to your shoulder when
you need it to so if you want to see
your character the way they move their
attire or maybe you just need a wider
viewpoint then rest assured it is here
but if you want to play this as an FPS
at present this option is not in the
final game I mentioned a shared world
well anthem is built to include other
players from two-player cooperative
missions to four player experiences it
can seem that this is not meant to be
played alone Bioware have come out of
the shadows that anthem will not force
you to play with others if you don't
want to so unplug your mic switch your
ID to offline and play alone if that's
your bag not many games can blend single
and multiplayer experiences so let's
hope anthem can do it oh and by the way
it's literally drop in and join your
team
they're looking good let's look at those
damn sexy exosuits
the freelancers are wearing these bad
boys are called javelins and will be
your mode of transport and the
MechWarrior suits all in one each
character class will have a different
skillset
most likely in line with many mmo's with
a tank class here to serve the front
line the other classes are less obvious
at the moment so I won't speculate just
yet
a recent bio edge which shows multiple
versions of each Jablin and what could
be seen as damage types or elemental
infusions this feeds into the destiny
vive I'm sure you are getting and it
looks like anthem is gunning for you
destiny players but one thing is very
different from destiny look at how you
get around this world a freakin jet back
like Iron Man what is not the look
speaking of destiny this will be a
Luther shooter meaning enemies and
missions will have a chance to drop gear
for you to use even legendary guns are
here but we'll get to that in a moment
public events look to be included what
they could be instance-based allowing
you and your crew to play without random
joining your foot on your side
[Music]
our story the story hasn't been fleshed
out at present but again it comes back
to destiny as humanity is protected by a
hulking Great Wall in four tosses you
play as a freelancer looking for work
and an adventurer - so you're ultimately
a mech soldier for hire the gunplay is
looking very that present with a scout
rifle being used to take down grunt then
the tank class bursts out a mortar
attack before our character straight up
uses Iron Man esque cluster rockets with
pinpoint targeting another character
picks up a volt rifle - that weapon drop
indicates there will be legendary or how
to acquire guns and gear with ranging
perks and stats the gun even has its own
name Yara's wrath which I'm sure will be
linked in game long
Bioware are four years into this project
already and have confirmed the game will
span the next 10 years sound familiar
whether that is through free or paid DLC
or anthem - suddenly appears in three
years there's a general shift for
persistent worlds at the moment which
are iterated upon and that seems like
the model that they are going for here
so expect anthem to be on your console
for quite a while finally there are
issues which have hurt by aware of
presence but these are seemingly ironed
out with erin-flynn by all where's
general manager seemingly taking the
fall for the mass effect prolonged
issues Casey Hudson has returned to head
Bioware and the game that he regards as
his baby yepp it's anthem there's a few
things that I'm worried about - and I'm
sure you've already heard about the
first of them the footage I'm using here
was retracted by Sony when the video was
shown to be using Xbox assets this isn't
a big deal for me as I've seen this for
many years with Xbox and Playstation
regularly using identical footage even
an early destiny video in 2014 included
a weapon on xbox which wasn't even
available on Xbox so things like this do
happen this was used by the way is not
true 4k either it uses checkerboard
upscaling on both ps4 and the Xbox 1x
the real issue for me is the fear I have
of the relationship between Xbox
and anthem I'm worried that some content
may be locked to the Xbox platform or be
time gated for Xbox users this has not
been said in any way so please don't
jump to any conclusions but at present I
am skeptical this kind of thing was the
number one reason why I refused to buy
any DLC for the division but it's also
the reason why I am buying destiny 2 so
I feel pretty conflicted here it looks
like we have a tough decision to make
anyway when it comes out with all that
said and done I dare to behave for
anthem even though it's a long way away
what about you what do you think of
anthem do you think you'll be picking
this one up I'll be keeping an eye on
this one and I'll keep you updated near
the launch I'm I don't on playstation
grenades
it's been a pleasure I'll see you next
time
[Music]